Prof: We're going to
talk about the war today.
Let's do that.
I assume that you guys all saw
Paths of Glory,
so I'm going to talk about the
mutinies in a while.
Jay Winter is going to talk
about essentially the Great War
in modern memory.
To make a nice transition to
his lecture,
I'm going to end with something
that he wrote about how reality
and art came together in a
terrifying way in 1918.
Okay.
Now--;comment faire
ça?
Qu'est ce qu'on va
faire?--so,
just a few things at the
beginning that are obvious.
They're in the book.
It didn't work out the way
Schlieffen wanted it to.
The point about the invasion of
Belgium was that it brought
Britain into the war.
The Germans were counting on
the fact that it would take
Britain a very,
very long time to raise an
army, not a navy but an army of
any size.
What they called the British
Expeditionary Force does arrive
and takes its place next to the
French.
But it's very small and they
don't have conscription until
late in the war.
Unlike the French,
they did not have military
conscription.
Basically, to make a long story
short,
in part because Germany,
as France,
as everybody was worried about
the home front,
basically what happens is they
hurt their chances of pulling
this off by moving some
divisions to Alsace to try to
blunt the force there.
Also, some more are headed off
to the eastern front,
because they start to realize
that the Russians are mobilizing
more rapidly than they thought
they could.
Basically, it's possible to
argue that the Battle of the
Marne saves Paris and saves
France.
Schlieffen would have gone
crazy about this.
Remember, the last thing he
said supposedly in his life was,
"Let the last soldier
touch the English Channel and
then come down and hit
Paris."
But they turned down before
that, and the first airplanes
are used as reconnaissance
planes.
The pilots literally had to
carry pistols with them at the
very beginning.
They had not figured out a way
to put machine guns on that the
bullets wouldn't hit the
propeller and then come back and
kill the pilot.
So, all this took some doing.
But the first planes were
reconnaissance planes.
At one point in this huge
engagement featuring enormous
armies,
in the German case supplied by
trains going many every hour
across the Rhine,
the French planes see that
there's a big gap in the German
lines.
So, they counter attack in the
famous story everybody knows.
Again, what I want to insist on
is--look at where it says Battle
of the Marne.
There's a town called Lagny
there.
Now it's practically a suburb
of Paris, L-A-G-N-Y.
You could hear the battle in
Paris.
You could hear the roll of
thunder of the guns.
When you ask how the French
home front holds together so
long, it's that the Germans are
so close.
In 1918, they will be close
again.
In 1918, they're firing this
huge gun which the British
soldiers called "Big
Bertha."
It's lobbing from way,
way the hell up in the north.
It's lobbing shells from behind
the German lines all the way to
Paris on Easter Sunday 1918.
It hit an apartment house on
the Church of Saint Gervais,
another hit an apartment house
on the Boulevard Port Royal,
one on the Rue de Rivoli not
too far from our place.
The Germans are so close.
But in 1914 what happens is
that literally the commander of
Paris, whose name was Gallieni.
He has a métro stop
named after him.
A lot of these guys do.
He commandeers the Paris taxis.
They are literally carrying
soldiers out to the front at the
Battle of the Marne.
What happens is the Battle of
the Marne stops the German
advance and then the race to the
sea begins.
They try to outflank each other.
Again, to borrow a ridiculous
football analogy,
but it's not so ridiculous.
It doesn't matter if you don't
follow football.
If you're trying to get around
the outside before the outside
linebacker can get there and
you're trying to turn the
corner.
Basically, that's what they're
trying to do.
Both sides are trying to turn
the corner and they end up at
the sea.
At that point,
the trenches are dug literally
from the sea all the way to
Switzerland.
The war, to repeat what I said
the other day,
only a couple people who had
seen what was going on in the
Russo-Japanese War of 1904-1905
could have imagined this war in
which the offense was supposed
to have, as in 1870-1871,
every advantage.
Remember the French commander
said élan vital,
"We need the frenetic
patriotic energy.
That's all we need.
We need to attack and keep on
attacking."
It doesn't work out that way.
The reason that you have all of
these millions of people killed,
the flower of British youth,
the flower of every youth in
that period,
is because this offense war
becomes a defensive struggle in
which breaking through is almost
literally impossible.
Thus, backdrop to what you have
seen in Paths of Glory.
The weapons of the war
including the shelling,
most people are killed by
shells in World War I than dying
in any other way.
There are new and horrible ways
of dying, flame throwers,
for example,
poison gas,
which is first used by the
Germans at Ypres,
on of the many battles of Ypres.
There are twelve battles of the
same river in northern Italy.
There are several battles of
the Somme.
These battles keep on
happening, because large chunks
of real estate are virtually
impossible to conquer.
So, trenches are defensive
weapons.
One of the reasons that the
breakthrough is impossible is
that when you're going to try to
break through these trenches,
what they have is what they
call creeping barrages.
They start trying to--and lots
of people died with what the
Americans call friendly
fire--they try to coordinate the
shelling to go in advance of the
people going over the top and
then trying to carry sixty
pounds--pick up sixty pounds
some time--worth of stuff on
your back,
and go down into these horrible
craters full of all sorts of
crap,
and dead floating rats,
and dead floating bodies of
human beings,
and to try to break through.
Then you run into machine guns.
Machine guns which can fire
what?
I just saw this morning or last
night.
I think it's 600 rounds a
minute.
The Gatling guns had first been
used in, I think,
the American Civil War.
But these are much more rapid
firing.
They aim basically at your
knees.
They just sort of go back and
forth, back and forth.
Then barbed wire.
One of the things that soldiers
had to carry with them were wire
cutters.
Sometimes the wire cutters
weren't equal to the task of
cutting the wire.
It's hard to cut wire if people
are firing machine guns at you
as well.
That's why the trenches,
which you'll see some real ones
in a minute, are fairly
elaborate defensive weapons.
Everybody has seen the footage
of real battle.
Sometimes--they've wrecked it,
but the Imperial War Museum,
which used to be much better
than it is now in London,
but it's really worth seeing.
They used to have this amazing
small clip.
You see these three guys and
they're about ready to go.
One guy blows his whistle to
say, "Follow me."
The first guy goes up and he
gets his head over.
Then he's dead.
He falls back.
The second guy goes up and he
gets a little further.
Then you see his body hit.
The third guy,
when the clip ends,
is just about to get out.
You don't know what happens to
him, but his chances weren't
very good.
Breaking through.
There are debates on how
ridiculous these people like
Nivelle were,
or Foch, and Joffre and the
whole gang, because they keep
ordering these attacks.
"The breakthrough is going
to come next.
We've really got them.
We're going to break
through."
But they don't break through.
And they don't break through.
They can't break through.
That is background for the
mutinies.
The first real breakthrough
doesn't come until March,
1918, in the Ludendorff
offensive, 1918.
Then they overrun their
supplies, and it kind of snaps
back like a rubber band and
pushes them back.
The Germans,
at that point,
for reasons I'll explain in a
minute, know that they're not
going to win the war.
They can't win the war.
What's going to happen is that
when the war ends,
and more about this when we
talk about the post-war,
is that the war ends with
German troops far inside France.
How do you explain that back to
the home front?
The Berlin home front has
started to collapse.
There's great deprivation,
great problems getting enough
to eat.
And that situation,
that will make it easier,
later,
for Hitler and many other
little would-be Hitlers to argue
that you were winning,
but you were stabbed in the
back by the Jews,
and the Communists,
and the Socialists,
and the peaceniks,
and all of these people,
from their point of view.
When you do these creeping
barrages, you're indicating
where the attack is going to
come.
Behind the trenches the
Germans, as do the French,
have railroad lines that are
used to bring in reinforcements,
to bring in supplies.
What you do is you bring in
supplies.
You bring in reinforcements.
If you read a great book by
Paul Fussell called The Great
War in Modern Memory,
it's about the war poets.
It's about Siegfried Sassoon,
and Wilfred Owen,
and folks like that.
Eisenberg, I quote him.
I think one of his poems is in
the book.
That is an amazing look at the
whole thing.
That's a ready-made paper
topic, to take a couple of those
poems and talk about the war.
Breaking through is very,
very difficult.
It's almost impossible.
That's why you have the carnage.
That's why you have,
as I said the very first day if
you were here,
that there were more British
soldiers killed or seriously
wounded in the first three days
of the Battle of the Somme,
like the river,
than there were Americans
killed in World War I,
Korea,
and Vietnam.
In three days.
The first three days.
You're talking about horrific
losses.
You're talking about an
expectation.
Try to put yourself in the same
thing.
I think I have that quote in
there.
Somebody said,
"You discuss your own
death as if you were discussing
a lunch that you were planning
tomorrow."
Someone else said,
"I didn't want to die,
at least until I'd finished
reading The Return of the
Native."
That, again,
is background for the mutinies.
What is amazing is that--;and
again,
the French situation because of
the precariousness--it's
difficult to explain how people
could have continued to fight in
many ways.
Again, looking at the
Austro-Hungarian Empire where
they had huge losses.
The armies hold together,
really, until 1917 and even
beyond the Austro-Hungarian
Empire.
The Russian case,
too, is remarkable.
The Battle of Tannenberg is
just an amazing battle in 1914.
There are so many casualties
they couldn't even count them.
There's so many people dead.
There had never been a war like
this.
No one had ever seen,
couldn't have imagined a war
like this.
The proximity,
also, the English had the
advantage of having the channel
there.
But it's one of these,
if you've been to Victoria
Station, it's one of these
things they always say about the
war, but it's true.
You go to the officer's club in
Victoria Station,
have a decent lunch,
knock down a couple pints of
beer,
and you're on the front and can
be dead by early evening.
It is said that in Kent,
where the miners,
these Welsh miners in Belgium,
they tunnel under this sort of
promontory that's sticking up,
that's a defensive position for
the Germans.
They bring in all these
munitions and they blow the
thing up.
They blow this huge thing up.
In Kent supposedly it is said
that people in Kent on and near
the coast of the English Channel
could actually hear the
explosion.
The war is that close.
Of course, it's close in other
ways.
Imagine that you lived in a
village in France or anywhere.
The facteur,
or, in our case,
the factrice,
the mail carrier comes.
What you don't want to see is
you don't want the mail carrier
to come to your house.
You don't want mail.
He would be carrying a telegram
saying,
"Be proud of X,
who has just died for"
you fill in the
country--Turkey,
Bulgaria, Romania,
France, Germany,
Russia, Britain,
anywhere.
So, it became a war like no
other war, with the only
possible exception the Spanish
Civil War.
It has given birth to really
the greatest writing about
arguably any war,
certainly, in history,
and arguably any events outside
of maybe the rise of Hitler and
National Socialism in Germany.
It was like that.
It really couldn't have been
any other way.
They're still arguing over
these battles.
Passchendaele,
we once drove up--Passchendaele
was one of these places that
they first used poison gas.
Now it's a lot of
lotissements,
in Belgium, a lot of housing
developments.
I just wanted to go and see
there.
You can't even see there where
the hell that was Passchendaele
was actually there.
If you're going to go see these
battlefields,
the one to go to is Verdun,
which I'll talk about in a
minute.
There you can go through these
forts, Douaumont and Vaux,
to imagine what it's like.
You can see some places where
they've left,
in the winds,
and the mists,
and the terrible--of that part
of France.
The one road going from Bar Le
Duc, on the sacred road,
supplying Verdun.
You still see there's one place
where they've left the guns with
their bayonets.
There was a lot of hand-to-hand
fighting there.
That's the place where
Falkenhayn said,
"We can afford to lose
more children,
more young people,
more young men.
We will simply outbleed
them."
He hurdles one attack after
another over most of 1916
against Verdun.
That's where so many people die.
Of course, that is the
background also for these
mutinies.
Okay.
Here's the western front in
1915-1917.
You can see that it really
doesn't move at all.
Again, there is Paris and there
is fighting.
By the way, these places like
Reims, with the beautiful
cathedral which was rebuilt
thanks to the Americans after
the war.
The Carnegie family gave a lot
of money, and ordinary people
rebuilt the cathedrals.
One of the great cathedrals
anywhere in Europe.
Reims was right on the line.
Of course, Reims just got
pounded.
The whole place was just
totally devastated.
Arras, there's another example
up there, right on the line.
I can't remember on the first
day or not if I didn't relate a
story of people that we knew,
now about eight years ago,
who were actually killed
because of World War I.
They were killed.
There's a family we knew who
were cousins of really good
friends of ours that would come
down there.
There was a boy the age of my
daughter then.
I guess he was twelve then.
We met them and we had a good
time talking to them.
Then I asked how they were at
Thanksgiving when I went over at
Thanksgiving.
In France we don't celebrate
Thanksgiving,
but I had ten days,
so why not?
They were dead.
Not the father,
but the son and the mother had
been killed by World War I.
Their house was right in Arras
and in the basement they had a
fire.
This was just a few--you were
ten years old when this
happened.
This was World War I.
Still killing.
They were killed because there
was a fire in their basement.
They didn't know that on the
other side of the wall were all
these munitions stocked right
near the front on World War I.
The fire caught and it blew up
the house.
The father wasn't there and
this little guy and his mother
were killed, were blown up,
killed by World War I.
In the 1920s there were people
killed all the time.
Every couple of weeks--you
still see in the paper now that
they found a bomb in Berlin from
World War II from all the
bombing,
or in Dresden and in all these
other places.
In World War I,
there were constantly farmers
who were blown up as they were
plowing, constantly,
as they were plowing on these
battlefields around the Chemin
des Dames, for example.
You can see the Somme there.
That's a good one to have there.
But the Chemin des Dames is up
near there.
It's north of Soissons.
Anyway, if you go to any of
those
départements,
if you go to the Marne,
which is where the Somme
basically was,
or in the Pas de Calais,
which is Picardie there,
there are just fields and
fields of these cemeteries there
with hundreds of thousands of
crosses.
One can go on and on about
this, but there had never been
anything like it.
So, war became the dominant
experience in the lives of
Europeans, period.
No matter how old you were,
you knew somebody who died.
You had a relative who died,
period.
There are in France,
where much of the fighting
was--the western front fighting
was there,
and in Belgium,
there are 36,000 communes,
which is an administrative
unit, 36,000.
Twelve out of 36,000 had nobody
killed in World War I.
There are places you can go,
particularly if you're in the
south of France,
where you can go.
They were all taken.
People who were skilled
workers, who could work in
munitions factories,
could get out.
There were a lot of tensions
between rural and urban people,
because urban people who had
rationing problems said,
"Oh,
the rural people are hoarding
their products"
and stuff like that.
But there are places you can go
where you see these,
and I'm a counter.
I count things all the time.
It's maddening.
You'll find there's one town
where seventy-four people died.
A very small town in the south
of France, in the Aveyron.
There are hardly seventy-four
houses.
There's a village that's quite
beautiful.
It's a twelfth century church
way up in the Cévennes
mountains where we take
tourists.
When you walk there,
the monument to the dead is
inside the church.
When you show people this
beautiful Renaissance entryway,
portail,
there's twelve people killed in
the war.
You cannot count.
There aren't twelve houses.
You can't count twelve houses.
People don't live there anymore.
Hardly anyone's there.
We know more about the western
front and now there's some good
books appearing on the eastern
front,
but it's the same thing in
every country that you're
talking about.
The numbers of people killed
around will make clear what the
countries were that really
suffered the most.
They were Germany and France,
followed by Russia,
but also Britain.
Don't forget Britain.
Remember I said four empires
disappear?
The fifth empire arguably
disappears in the end,
because of dynamics caused by
the war.
People in the so-called
colonies fighting for the
British Empire,
they began to think,
"Why shouldn't we have
independence?
Why shouldn't we have freedom,
too?"
Of course, at the Battle of
Gallipoli,
which is one of the great
tragedies of the war when
Churchill,
who had ten ideas a day and
nine of them were bad,
as one of his critics said,
Churchill said,
"We'll take the pressure
off.
We'll knock the Turks out of
the war."
They're going to have this
impossible assault on Turkish
fortified positions.
They said, "We'll knock
them out of the war with the
Australians, and the Indians,
and the New Zealanders.
We can afford to lose them more
easily.
They're not really ours."
Of course, that still resonates
in places like New Zealand,
and Australia,
and India, as well it should.
Anyway, that's another
complicated story,
and we have other stuff to do.
Read things on this.
It is a phenomenal thing.
Mutinies.
Just a little bit to the
mutinies.
The Somme you can read about,
and all of that.
When I used to work at
Vincennes,
in the military archives there,
because I was writing about
1830 and 1848 and all that
stuff,
I was reading day by day the
correspondence from various
regions in France.
I was trying to find these
documents that I knew were
there.
This was when I was just
starting out.
I wasn't much older than you
guys.
I'd like to think that.
Younger than I once was,
but anyway, whatever the song
is.
And I knew the stuff was there.
The person that ran it was out
having sort of a torrid affair
with this guy all the time.
So, she was never there at
lunch.
And she didn't know what she
was doing anyway.
I bribed one of the guards to
let me back in the stacks where
you're not supposed to go in
French archives.
But the guy was a stamp
collector and I knew that.
So, I kept leaving all these
jazzy stamps on my table.
Finally he said,
"Oh, those are beautiful
stamps.
"Would you like them?"
The next thing I knew I'm in
the back.
I remember what I saw was this
huge thing of boxes.
This is in the mid-1970s.
This huge number of boxes that
were literally chained up.
They were in this cage and they
were chained up,
really chained up with big
locks and all that stuff,
big security.
I said, "What's all
that?"
He said, "Those are the
mutiny documents.
Those are the documents from
the mutinies in 1917."
Now, finally,
a guy was able to get in,
because in France there's a
fifty-year rule and he should
have been able,
fifty years after the fact,
he should be able to consult
documents.
This guy was finally able to
get exception to go work on
these documents.
So, the thesis that was
published is very good,
by a guy called Guy Pedroncini,
whom I don't know,
and it's on the mutiny.
Now we know about the mutinies.
What do we know about the
mutinies that confirms what you
saw in the film?
Several things.
The mutinies spread rapidly.
They did, indeed,
begin with soldiers who were
being sent the front baa-ing
like sheep,
as if they were being sent to a
slaughterhouse,
because that's what they're
being sent to.
What's the difference between a
soldier carrying sixty pounds of
equipment going to some attack
that's going to go nowhere,
where his chances of being
killed are enormous,
and sheep being led to a
slaughterhouse?
What is the difference?
Really not much,
except you're dealing with a
human being and not a sheep.
That was a bad sign for these
officers.
When the mutinies started,
there were only really four
reliable divisions,
they figured at one point,
between Paris and the German
lines.
The incredible thing was--is
because soldiers never talk
about the battle when they go
back.
They don't talk about the
battle.
It was impossible to
communicate what was going on.
The mutinies were one of the
well-kept secrets.
Nobody knew.
The Germans didn't know at the
time.
Hardly anybody knew.
Nobody is probably too strong.
The mutinies involved
thousands, and thousands,
and thousands of soldiers.
In some cases they elected
people to represent them.
In a few cases where the
officers maintained the upper
hand, they summarily shot
mutineers.
Do you say mutineers?
I don't know, people who mutiny.
I confuse these things.
They were massive.
But they had nothing to do with
socialist, or anarchist,
or pacifist propaganda at all.
There were attempts.
There were congresses.
There was a congress in Sweden.
There was another one in
Switzerland.
The French government would not
let representatives go to those
congresses.
The first reaction in the high
command was that,
"Well, the socialists are
now showing their true stripes.
Anarchist propaganda is
working."
Look at the Bolshevik
Revolution.
It had not yet happened.
That was in October,
but the Russian Revolution in
February had already occurred.
It has nothing to do with it.
What they objected to,
they were not defeatists at
all.
They did not want the Germans
to win the war.
But they realized that they
weren't going to win the war
either and that this strategy
was completely futile.
There were cases of
fraternization.
They are very famous cases.
Christmas 1914,
on the front way up near
Belgium, on the British side
particularly.
They start yelling back and
forth, the Germans and the
British.
They say basically,
"Screw this stuff.
Why don't we take the day
off?"
So, the Welsh were singing
Christmas carols to the Germans
and the Germans were getting
their best singers and singing
back.
They actually did get together
and play a soccer game.
They found a place that wasn't
totally chopped up and played.
In 1915 on Christmas a British
soldier said,
"Why don't we do the same
thing?"
They put him up against the
wall and shot him.
There were these rumors that
were very persistent during the
whole fighting on the western
front that underneath,
underneath Reims--where,
after all,
were all these champagne caves,
or underneath Albers.
That was the town where the
statue of the Virgin Mary on the
top of a church hung like this.
The Germans said if it falls
one way we're going to win.
If it falls the other way,
the French are going to win.
That somewhere the people who
are lucky enough to be alive
were down there.
They would come out and take
food, and they would take wine
rations, and stuff like that.
They would take them back from
the dead, and they were all
partying underground.
They were the lucky ones.
They were all fraternizing.
It wasn't that case.
Still, you hear all these
stories.
The great war poets sort of
saying, "Yeah,
this German guy and a British
guy find themselves in a crater,
both on the verge of death,
and they're discussing
Nietzsche until somebody finally
comes and rescues them."
A lot of this may be apocryphal.
But the mutinies had to do not
with defeatism;
it had to do with the sheer
madness of it all.
It was mad.
And there are still historians
who are saying,
"Well,
the creeping barrages,
if they had made them a little
bit more organized then maybe
the breakthroughs would have
come."
They're still defending the
impossible after all of these
years--Something happened.
I want to show you these,
please.
I think I'm turning it off.
Simon, can you--?
I am nul.
It was very dark at the Battle
of Verdun.
What happens?
Could you do this?
Okay.--These are real ones from
Verdun.
Verdun was 1916.
It begins in February.
It rains all the time in that
part of France.
To explain the mutinies is also
to understand Verdun.
This is a reconnaissance plane.
Those are craters there.
Those are some more craters
over there.
That's Fort Douaumont or Vaux.
When you go to them,
and you really should go to
them, it's a long way from
Verdun.
Verdun is the town that's near
there.
The one I'll never forget is
when you go in and you
see--after the war,
like as people do in churches,
people would come and put
plaques--the most moving one is
"To my son,
since his eyes closed.
Mine have not ceased to
cry."
Next one, please.
So, you'd be going in there.
Those are where the plaques
are, right there.
In fact, that plaque that I
just said is right next to that.
Now, you're here and they say,
"Over the top,
men."
You're trying to get on the
other side there.
How are you going to do that?
That's all barbed wire around
there.
How are you going to do that?
You can't.
That's inside Vaux or Douaumont.
Night patrol.
Again, there's the trench.
They're attacking.
But you've got to climb over
your own barbed wire,
too.
That's barbed wire that's
protecting you from if they
attack.
The casualty rates are just
absolutely phenomenal at all
these.
The casualty rates here are not
the same as the Somme,
because it wasn't a massive
attack.
You're defending it against the
Germans.
They're taking care of some
people that have been hurt,
carrying somebody back.
The poor guy looks a little
peaked there.
Telephones.
The Russian phone system was so
bad the Germans could hear every
single word that they said on
the eastern front.
Next, please.
Well, you get the point.
There's the machine guns aimed
low--medical.
That's fantastic to walk in
there.
But you have to remember that a
lot of the fighting is on the
outside in the mists,
and the snow,
and the crap.
It's an amazing thing.
But they held.
They held.
Marshall Pétain became
the hero of France.
He would have a later
incarnation in World War II.
We'll get back to him.
They hold.
How are you going to run up
that hill carrying sixty pounds?
There's a commune, by the way,
called Douaumont,
which is the only commune out
of the 36,000 that no longer
exist because it was so battered
that there's a difference in
height in these hills of fifty
and 100 feet.
It could never be rebuilt.
Next, please.
We get the scene.
It's amazing how little people
knew.
What they knew on the home
front,
and there's a very good book
edited by Jay Winter and his
friend,
Jean-Louis Robert,
about capital cities at war,
about London,
Paris, and Berlin,
comparing the home front.
It's really good stuff,
how little people knew about
this.
It's like an Italian said,
"Do people really imagine
that we just jump up and down
screaming ‘Long Live
Italy'?"
One of the most amazing things
is that people in the hell,
actually that more of them
didn't mutiny.
That's one of the most
incredible things about the
whole bloody mess.
They died in hell,
they called it Passchendaele.
That was a place where the
British gained four miles,
that's about seven kilometers,
in exchange for 300,000 dead or
wounded, 300,000.
Take a football stadium like
University of Michigan or UT
Austin and fill it up three
times, and imagine that you know
those people.
That's what it was like.
1917 changes everything.
1917 changes everything because
two key events happen,
and they're obvious.
One is the Russian Revolution
in 1917 in February.
That's A.
Then B, and this is still point
number one, is the Russian
Revolution in October.
It's clear that the--we'll talk
about this or you can read about
this.
The Kerensky provisional
government is under tremendous
pressure from the allies to stay
in the war.
But it is clear that when the
Bolsheviks seize power in
October 1917,
the Russians are going to get
out of the war.
"Peace,
land, and bread"
is a powerful,
powerful slogan for the Russian
soldiers.
It's amazing that the Russian
soldiers didn't all go
back to Vladivostok,
or to Kazakhstan,
or to wherever,
that they were able to hold on
as long as they did.
That's going to change things.
It's at that time that the
second event happens.
That is the Americans come into
the war.
The Americans--outside of
places like Chicago,
and Milwaukee,
and Philadelphia maybe,
they had lots of Germans--most
people in the United States,
the tendency was to want the
allies to win,
to fight another day,
and the Americans were angered
by the submarine warfare
campaign.
In 1915, a boat called the
Lusitania was sunk.
There had been warnings posted
by the German government,
saying, "If you're a
passenger, don't go on that.
You're going into a war
zone."
The Germans claim when the boat
was sunk that it was full of
munitions.
The Americans and the British
said, "No,
it wasn't."
In fact, it was.
That was proved about
twenty-years-ago by divers.
It sunk near Ireland and lots
of people died.
The Germans know that the only
way they can win the war is the
unrestricted campaign of
submarine warfare to try to keep
Britain from being supplied by
American supplies.
Woodrow Wilson,
Princeton, who won the
election, kept us out of war.
He takes the country into war,
and eventually he can't get the
Treaty of Versailles passed even
by the American isolationist
senate.
So, the Americans go to war in
1917.
I took Yale alumni,
besides taking them to the
Épernay to drink
champagne,
a lot of them wanted to go to
this a long time ago,
to Chateau Thierry,
which is the first place that
American soldiers fought in
1917.
Now, it wasn't the American
troops that made the difference.
In the imaginary,
the imaginaire,
in the perceptions of the
French,
it was the arrival of General
Pershing,
who had made his career
slaughtering Mexicans in Mexico.
The image was that the far west
was coming and these sort of
gun-toting Dodge City types were
going to turn the tide.
That's not what happens.
What turns the tide is that
once the Americans are in the
war, the tremendous industrial
strength of the U.S.
means the curves are going to
cross.
By that simply I mean the
curves that the Germans know
they aren't going to win the
war.
The British,
and the French,
and the American high command
know they're going to win the
war.
They think they're going to win
the war in 1920 or 1921,
maybe 1919, if all goes well.
There was a quote in there
after they just had--at the cost
of thousands of lives--I think
it's still in there.
They had gotten a couple of
kilometers of territory back
from the Germans.
Somebody says,
"At this rate,
we'll get to the Rhine in the
year 2006,"
I think is what they figured.
The long duration,
of being in until the end,
was going to be a long time,
if you were able to survive.
Those are the two big events,
the curves cross.
1917 is also an important year
because tanks begin to make a
difference.
Tanks can't do anything in
these craters.
They get stuck.
Their treads just sort of spin
like a car stuck in the snow in
North Haven or something.
They don't make any difference
until actually they can break
into the open.
At that point,
then they can be a way of
protecting infantry behind them.
So, 1917 really turns it around.
To make a long story short yet
again, in 1918,
by this time,
Hindenburg and Ludendorff
basically have taken over the
government.
Basically, the Second Reich is
now controlled by the military.
Of course, Hindenburg has a
rather pernicious role in the
long run to play.
He was determined to destroy
the Weimar Republic,
even though he was president.
As he in 1932 says,
"We'll bring in the Adolf.
We'll bring him in as
chancellor."
So, Ludendorff said,
"Look, we've got to do it
now.
If we don't do it now,
it's never going to
happen."
So, they throw every
conceivable resource into this
offensive.
They do break through.
You can look at the maps in the
book.
They get a long way.
But then it snaps back like a
rubber band.
They overrun their supplies,
as they had in 1914,
in the big war offensive in
1914.
They begin to overrun their
supplies.
They get tired and then they're
pushed back.
At that point,
the worst days of the
bombardment of Paris have ended.
The allies are sure they're
going to win the war,
and that the Germans and the
Austro-Hungarian Empire,
which is almost on the verge of
collapse,
despite the sheer inefficiency
of the Italian military,
they know that it's going to
collapse and that Russia's
coming out of the war in the
long run did not make that much
of a difference.
The Italians are able to
stabilize the front in
Austria-Hungary,
and the whole thing is going to
collapse.
And the Austrian-Hungarian
Empire, the nationalities are
putting forth their claims.
Franz Joseph dies in 1916,
and it's not going to go on
that long.
Finally, on the 11^(th) of
November 1918,
in a railroad car near
Compiegne in the forest,
not very far north of Paris,
they sign on the dotted line
and the armistice is declared.
In 1940, Hitler would accept
France's surrender.
It wasn't actually the same
railroad car,
but they told him it was,
also in the forest near
Compiegne in 1940.
The war ended.
More about this later.
Basically, France in victory is
not as strong as Germany in
defeat.
Germany is industrially a much
more prosperous country.
This will hang over the
negotiations at Versailles,
because the French demand that
somebody pay for the war,
which France suffered more than
any other country in terms of
its agricultural land being
chewed up,
the finest land in France,
etc., etc.
That's going to hang over the
peace proceedings.
I want to make just a few
comments before I end with Jay
Winter.
We have five minutes left,
so I'm going to do that.
The highest percentage of
losses was France,
with 16.8 percent of those
mobilized killed.
In Germany, 15.4 percent killed.
But if you take those in
combat, it's twenty-two percent
officers and eighteen percent
soldiers.
Remember, officers weren't all
fancy generals who were sitting
drinking champagne,
plotting the deaths of all
these people.
The junior officers,
and this is also the case in
the British sense,
the flower of British youth
from Oxford, Cambridge,
etc., etc.,
they're the ones that blew the
whistle and said,
"Follow me, men."
And they jump over,
armed with only a pistol.
They're toast.
They get killed in even greater
percentages.
Anyway, Serbia loses
thirty-seven percent of all its
combatants.
They don't have as many.
Turkey, twenty-seven percent;
Romania, twenty-five percent;
and Bulgaria,
twenty-two percent.
Now, think of this.
The war starts in early August,
1914, and it ends on the
11^(th) of November,
1918.
Every day of those years,
every day.
Think four years back in your
own lives, and then every day,
900 Frenchmen were killed every
day, every day.
That's a lot of telegrams.
"Be proud of X."
1,300 Germans were killed every
day.
The death rate was higher in
World War II.
Of course, in World War II,
the Soviet Union has an
unbelievable death rate,
twenty-five million people die,
some of them in Stalin's Gulag,
but most of them because of the
war.
The death rate is higher.
July 1,1916,
the first day of the Battle of
the Somme, 20,000 British
soldiers were killed.
Not just killed and wounded,
dead in one day.
They were there to go over the
top, and they're dead at the
end.
Unlike previous wars,
disease didn't play a major
part.
Unlike, for example,
the Crimean War.
Though the Blue Flu,
sometimes called the Spanish
Flu, as you know will kill more
people in 1918,1919,
and 1920, than the war.
That's the pandemic.
As I said, most people die of
shells, followed by machine guns
and flames, despite progress in
medicine.
Also, things like shell shock
were first identified at this
time after the war.
Freud was very interested in
that, among other people.
The psychological--I
wasn't--you went into the Paris
Metro or the London Tube and you
saw people begging with one arm,
or one leg, or no legs.
You saw people who had also
choked out their lungs on gas or
who were blind.
They were all over the place.
Europe was a country of widows,
especially in countries like
Italy where widows still wore
black all the time.
Europe was a country of widows.
If you had a demographic curve,
a triangle,
it was like a shark had eaten a
huge bite out of the male
population between eighteen and,
say, fifty-five.
The length was simply
staggering.
The Battle of the Somme lasted
five months.
Gallipoli lasted more than
eight months.
Verdun, ten months.
Ypres, in 1917, four months.
On the Battle of the Somme,
you talk about how war
influenced people's lives,
four million men participated
in the Battle of the Somme,
four million.
That's a phenomenal statistic.
More than a quarter were
killed, captured,
or porté
disparu,
classified as disappeared,
nothing left.
Battlefields were no longer
called the field of glory.
That went.
The language went.
I make an allusion to that,
which is an obvious one,
at the end of what you read.
Also, there's a brutalization
of the sense of humanity that
you lost because you were
dealing with so many people dead
all around.
You were fighting for your life.
The attitude that people had
toward other people changes,
and the demons of the twentieth
century--fascism above
all--would be built on that
dehumanization.
Difficult to imagine,
though not impossible,
the Holocaust without World War
I;
but given the Turks and what
they did to the Armenians,
it's hard to say.
Also, atrocities.
There were atrocities.
Now there are a couple of good
books on atrocities.
Most of the atrocities were
committed by the Germans in
Belgium.
They executed 5,500 Belgian
civilians.
Edith Cavell was the most
famous, the nurse.
In part because German soldiers
believed that they were being
picked off by civilians--is what
had happened in France in
1870-1871.
But the Russians committed
atrocities in east Prussia and
in Galicia.
The Austrians,
who had been told that the
Serbs were subhuman,
committed atrocities there.
There were rapes.
Rape had not yet become an arm
of combat as it would with the
Russians after World War II,
but people were treated like
animals.
Hitler said in 1939,
"After all,
who will remember the
Armenians?"
That's an incredible,
chilling thing.
So, I want to end simply with
Jay Winter, whom you're going to
meet soon, assuming I can find
this.
It's about a haunting film done
by Abel Gance.
It's called J'Accuse,
I Accuse.
It's not the same thing as
Zola's I Accuse;
it's another one.
Made in 1918-1919.
The hero, Jean Diaz,
is a wounded soldier poet.
He begins to lose his mind.
He escapes from the hospital
and he reaches his village.
There he summons the villagers
and he tells them of a dream.
It starts on a battlefield
graveyard with wooden crosses
all here, and there,
and everywhere.
A huge black cloud rises above
it, and magically,
ghost-like figures emerge from
the ground.
They're wrapped in tattered
bandages, some limping,
some blind, walking with
upraised arms stumbling blindly
like Frankenstein's monster.
They leave the battlefield and
they go home.
They go from the grave to their
villages.
And they want to see if their
sacrifices have been in vain.
And they get back to their
villages and what they find is
that their wives have cheated on
them.
They find that people are still
ripping people off by false
weights at the market.
The petty ways have continued
despite their horrific losses.
They say, "You must mend
your ways.
We didn't go through all of
this hell so that you would
continue to behave like you do.
The world, after all,
must be a better place.
Isn't it a better place now?
Won't it be?"
That's the big illusion,
by the way, about 1920s and
1930s.
The world wasn't going to be a
better place.
It wasn't at all.
They believed their mission is
fulfilled.
They go back to their graves.
After recounting this dream,
the poet, now totally mad,
accuses the sun above of
standing idly by and watching
the war go on.
Then he dies.
The oddest thing about this,
about how art and reality
merge, is that this film was
made before the end of the war.
I'll bet Gance,
the producer,
got permission from the army to
have real soldiers be extras in
his movie.
You can see real people,
who are not going back to the
front, with their arms ripped
off.
Stumps.
They had stumps.
Some of the people who were in
that movie went back to the
front and were killed.
They didn't survive the war.
The war had taken a terrible
vengeance both in art,
the joys of great artistic
production, but on reality,
too.
It's an incredible scene.
Of course, things couldn't go
back again.
You couldn't go back to your
village.
You couldn't get off a bus at
the end,
and go back and fall into the
arms of your family,
and stand there with tears on
your cheeks as you were counting
off the names of the dead,
people that you knew.
Things were going to get
better, but they don't.
One way of looking at the
entire period of 1914 to 1945,
and Jay will talk about this,
is to view it as an entire,
more horrible Thirty Years'
War,
because things don't get better;
they get worse,
if that's even possible.
On that light note,
I wish you a happy election.